I'm very excited this told me because in
a way it represents really the hot of
what like tune of mathematics and by
extension well by extension
Accenture one mathematics it's really
like it's it's the hot it's what
everything flows form it's kind of like
the engine room I suppose of this entire
course right geometrical applications of
calculus is the menu and one of the
wonderful things about it is it's the
kind of title that enters its own
question ok so before we get stuck into
the first part of this topic I want to
understand that name and then just give
you a very like brief flyover of what
kind of terrain we're going to look at
because it's a great point ok so
whenever you see the word applications
ok in mathematics all we're referring to
years and there are two branches of
maths broadly speaking two really really
big thick branches pure mathematics and
applied mathematics now even though I'm
saying they're two things they aren't
really they are actually quite
interconnected but the whole idea is if
you're anything read this way pure
mathematics it's kind of mathematics for
its own sake like we're just gonna play
with these numbers or shapes or bless
you or anything like that just because
we can like why not right whereas
applied mathematics is we have problems
that exists in the world right and we
want to use mathematics to solve these
problems okay embellishments are
everything but anyway like again happen
therefore the side here is applications
which means okay good for you you can
differentiate but what can you do with
that differentiation like what is the
point of the differentiation what kinds
of problems
and what kinds of new understandings can
we apply it to ok so this is our seeing
a question of what can you do with it
that's what applications means what can
you do
at the moment within calculus the thing
that we do only thing that we know that
we can do something with is the
derivative right we will learn about
other things apart from the derivative
awareness turn now further we have one
big word that's missing in the title
itself right which is actually it's R so
this question so geometrical is all that
shape that's all that shape tell me this
shape there's something and one of the
most important applications of calculus
is to learn about the shape and behavior
of functions okay now I just sort of
snuck in a really sneaky word yeah
shape that naturally is what we think I
want to think here the tree but behavior
is kind of a new category for us to
think about but it's an immensely
helpful as a metaphor but it's like look
this function that we're dealing with
this function it's it's doing things
it's it's animate it wants to move
around and behavior certain way okay so
that's what this topic is all that there
are four particular big ideas that we're
going to cover and then they lead into
two big sort of well contexts in which
they are applied okay so let me show you
show you very quickly what the young 4d
values are geometrically speaking of
these in fact um they're all geometric
ideas firstly is a function right I
actually have this metaphor in my head
of like I own like a plane or an
elevator right is it going up or is it
going down okay now the technical term
that we would use for this is is it
increasing or is it decreasing if it's
neither again just like something that's
behaving and moving all right something
that's neither going up nor down is
still and the technically why we use
that is
stationary right so this is the first
big important question going up or going
down
increasing decreasing or not so firstly
we said going up or going down okay
secondly you remember we said more if
you're neither going up nor down like
you're you're still forever you're
stationary like that in fact that itself
is its own important question number one
are you stopping
are you stopping or importantly as it's
often the reason why you stopped are you
turning so respectively we would call
these stationary points or someone
originally turning points you were going
up and then you went down you've turned
around all by especially your and down
then going up you don't change direction
okay there's another crucial idea seven
really quickly the easiest way I'm going
to be able to illustrate this business
to draw it if I talk about something
like exponential growth exponential
growth so say to the X right it looks
like this it's to be it now this just
really quickly asked the question here
is it going up or going down
as I go from left to right which is the
way I always measure great yet it's
clearly going up don't you see that it's
growing on that's the exponential
function I'm going to compare it to its
inverse the universe of course of the
exponential function is the log function
now I want to ask the same question is
it going up or is it go down
it's still going up it never stops going
up it does slow down a lot but it never
actually stops now both of these guys
here are what we call our increasing
functions not just increasing but
monotonically increasing you know what
monotone means it means when someone
speaks in the same term and their tone
doesn't change right which eye focuses
primarily to now these are increasing
all the time
monotonically increasing but they are
clearly not increasing in the same way
like they don't even look the same right
they go enough right you're going up but
not the same way how could we describe
with my lips playing metaphor the
difference between these two
say that again level good it's a
question really of acceleration right
they're both going up okay but the
question is am i speeding on or am i
slowing down
now you remember I said we have
technical language all of these
geometric ideas right we would say
increase or decrease we might say
stationary or turning here the technical
word that you need to to flag when you
make it in a couple of weeks is
concavity or if they change
who's speeding up to slowing down I'm
still going up right all by special
right something like this
okay I'm slowing down slowing down
slowing down and then I start speeding
up that point there something
fundamental has changed we call it a
point of inflection we're gonna need it
to be a really important idea
one last geometric idea up or down
stopping turning speeding slowing the
lungs question is what's the highest to
get and what's the lowest to highest all
lowers now
yep
Hey okay so I'm trying to get across but
the ideas are and I don't want you to
get caught up with language okay I will
introduce the language you guys know how
much I love language okay but the
important thing is you see these are all
just shape ideas geometric ideas
behavior items
tell me what this thing is doing how
would you characterize it okay now the
technical phrase for these kinds of
things are maxima as in the plural of
maximum maxima and minima
okay um Hoku they're called max
pinnacles right now in fact that leads
me to my next thing which is that these
four ideas they are given to particular
expressions within the course okay so we
take all of these and we combine them in
two ways number one the select your
first big application curve sketchy
right for a long time you have been
sketching curves but for a lot of the
time you've had to say okay now do I
write the mother to draw it like this or
that or where does it do this and where
does it do that and we've had to say
well you don't have the tools available
just sketch this accurately you just get
a general idea well once we've got this
up Ashley you have all the tools anyone
has ever needed okay Kerr sketching the
first time secondly you need to write
this down if you don't like but um I
just love my just arm I learnt it fairly
recently because I was at the school I'm
pretty sure this is how it's not I'm
pretty close well I know I'm not gonna
even try and pronounce you
it's it's German so that's it that's a
big net to be sent this is what we call
in English optimization which means
frequently I think it means extreme
values frequently I want to change a
situation so I get the max or something
the most I can possibly get or I want to
get the smallest to some particular
quantity I'm trying to optimize for one
value or another okay so this is the
proper name for what is correctly
according in problems okay we're going
to get these geometric ideas and then
we're going to apply them through things